So part 2 on which economic policy in the European framework?
So basically we are going to see the establishment of the euro zone,
so now we have seen that there was a single market or a common market that had
been adopted between all the member countries of the European Union and then automatically
there was an adoption of a single currency
by the members of the European Union,
now that we can freely share goods or services between
the countries of the European Union,
it is even easier to make these exchanges if the country I buy buy from or the
country I buy from shares the same currency as me.
As a result,
you can also say that in 1988 there was a committee that was responsible
for setting the stages for the changeover to the euro and therefore
for a monetary economic union.
For example,
in the intermarkets we have seen the appearance of double prices,
the franc and the euro,
and basically it is on January 1,
1999 that the euro zone is really effective and basically on January 1,
2002,
the euro really starts to be exchanged and it
comes back into force more and more.
On the other hand,
countries like the United Kingdom before the history of the European
Union Denmark the Sweden members of the European Union that
refused permanently to be part of it.
Now we will see the effects of the market on economic growth since everything
is linked to these economic policies within the European framework have had
consequences on economic growth and the effects are rather positive.
We see them as a virtuous circle in the sense that these policies and
agreements have allowed companies to have a larger market,
so this has increased the opportunities of these companies that have
favored production and therefore have favored economic growth.
they had more customers so much more production therefore much more production much
more exchanges much more exchanges economic growth and all these market evolutions
it led to an economy of scale I remind you that an economy of scale refers to the
situation in which there is an increase in production which leads to a decrease in
the average unit cost of a product or a wholesale service since companies have more
customers because that basically the whole European Union
becomes their potential customer,
they are much more likely to exchange products or services in large quantities,
which leads to a decrease in their price.
It is also important to know that the decrease in production
costs leads to a decrease in prices,
thus allowing an increase in the purchasing power of consumers.
One of the other consequences is that these policies improve price competitiveness
- price competitiveness refers to the ability of companies to sell their
products at or below the price of their competitors.
We can say that I will make a small parenthesis with international trade
because basically these European economic policies lead
to a lot of competition for companies,
but in fact many people see competition between companies
as something harmful for them,
but in fact not at all because the presence of competition obliges companies
to always be dynamic and competitive with each other,
it encourages them to innovate,
etc.
And in fact,
these innovations make the company more and more dynamic and more dynamic,
and as a result,
these innovations also benefit consumers and accelerate economic growth.